oh good you're home that is proceeding
[Music]
proceeding babe I had a really long day
can I just change in my if you have a
seat please
there's a mystery foot what why are you
speaking in a British accent show you're
wondering why if someone you here to do
I live here I'm just trying to do a
thing perhaps II just want to do its the
thing oh my god
bacon Exhibit A I rinsed this bowl I
didn't wash it okay when you found it
later that night you said you were fine
with it when in fact you were not fine
it literally takes one extra second to
just lean down and put it in the
dishwasher it takes longer to do
whatever it is these don't you admit it
sorry I realize it yeah Exhibit B you
have four separate alarms do you not
okay this is like sort of ridiculous
answer the question yeah I have four
separate lives and when our smoldering
passions have ignited in the past you
used to set your alarm for the latest
possible time can you not say smoldering
passion what time's your alarm go off
this morning Lila Lila 6:15 the earliest
time yeah
the evidence is stacking up against you
my dear okay I'm gonna go change out of
my work clothes and finally Exhibit C
the most damning of them all symptoms
paper how long did it take you to make
that I call that a sick from work if you
would please turn your attention to the
bar graph you will notice that the
moaning column is unusually high while
the eye closing and the back arching is
weirdly low I'm sorry what does that
prove simply that in the absence of a
true orgasm you oversold the moan yeah
you drop it other like okay you're right
I knew it I just really stressed out and
I had that big meeting today so I
promise I won't do it again
okay it was just a one-time thing right
oh babe it was just a one-time thing
right
of course when you can tell if I'm
faking it right
[Music]